you made ITN you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos Happy
New Year we are back after a couple
weeks off and we are starting the new
year with a bang this is Joe got he's
incredible you know him from impr iCal
Jokers he's also a wonderful stand-up
comedian and you're about to hear a
wonderful Guy this is a very much a did
we just become Best Friends episode I
loved talking with him I'm so glad you
guys are here to check it out if you do
uh check the show out on YouTube we are
migrating all of the podcast episodes to
a dedicated YouTube channel just you
made it weird on YouTube to keep the
Pete Holmes YouTube channel where the
sketch and the standup is and you you
made it weird would be its own dedicated
thing just to kind of help people find
it and uh help the people that are
looking for it well I just said the same
thing twice didn't I but just go
subscribe it would be great if you
subscribe on YouTube to the you made it
weird uh podcast Channel check check
that out that's easy I'm also on the
road thank you to everybody that was out
at in Tempe it was awesome uh this
weekend I will be in Brea California so
go to Pete homes.com for tickets we also
have Chicago is rescheduled and more and
more dates being added there I love this
new hour I love this new tour it's so
fun and it always means so much when
weirdos come out we also have the Largo
show you can go to largo-la docomo that
monthly here in Los Angeles um that's L
the next one is on January 30th I'm also
doing the Netflix is a joke Fest here in
Los Angeles and there is a link to that
on Pete homes.com as well uh as you guys
know we only do ads for things that I
actually use and actually love with that
in mind this is a picture of me on the
Jimmy Kimmel show that I have here in my
office and this oops and this shirt this
is sloppy this shirt that I'm wearing is
from my new favorite apparel company and
my buddies at Roosevelts Roosevelts
which I got to get the spelling right
cuz it's not don't don't search
Roosevelts
rsvlts is an apparel brand born from
their passion for pop culture and
Americana they make some of the funnest
coolest designs combining high quality
products with bold unique Concepts uh
something for everybody their shirt
collections range from Star Wars they
got a lot of great Star Wars stuff
Disney Nickelodeon classic movies like
the big Labowski the office if you have
a pop culture fiend in your life or if
you are one they have a pattern that
looks amazing and is a great shout out
to the things that you love if your
Styles is a little bit more laid-back
like mine they also have just classic
patterns that look great and feel
amazing on your body you'll be the focus
of the room in one of their extremely
comfortable and laid-back original
designs their conversation starters and
it have been known to crack the shiest
person out of their shells so if you're
looking for fun highquality threads look
no further than my friends at
Roosevelt's light soft stretchy and fit
damn nice they're moisture wicking
they're extremely breathable it's like a
very modern feeling fabric it's called
kunu Flex it's a four-way stretch
material I love the fit I love the fun
ones Jurassic Park the office that's
great and if you want to look classy
like you're going on a late night talk
show Roosevelts has got you covered as
well they won't shrink or wrinkle after
washing which is why I wear them on
stage they're fantastic to travel with
they also make hats bomber jackets
performance hoodies which are awesome
and shorts they won't blame you if you
never want to take them off their
conversation starters as I said they're
based out of hobok and New Jersey which
is a plus clothing for The Bold and the
fun for those who dare Mighty things
just like their name sake Teddy
Roosevelt once said so if you want to
get your hands on some of these amazing
items visit rsvl ts.com so Roosevelts
sort of without the vowels
rsvlts dcom or check them out on
Instagram Roosevelts
rsvlts which is how I found them check
it out they are awesome get into it big
time and of course we brought to us
almost as always from our friends at
Magic mind I'm holding one here I've had
two magic Minds today because I did two
podcasts today it is a performance
drinking Miracle I'm saying it for real
everybody that knows me knows I love
magic mind I'm always giving it to the
guests cuz it really brings out that
creative Flow State it's about as much
caffeine as half a cup of coffee but
it's got new at Tropics to help you
think and has adaptogens to help you
calm your body down so it stimulates
your mind and calms your body which is
the perfect combination to get into that
flow State turn off procrastination get
writing get thinking get flowing get
laughing it's not a wired feeling it's a
dialed in feeling lasts about 5 to 7
hours and you get 30% more productivity
after drinking get that add out of there
get that brain fog out of there get that
fatigue out of there and drop into Flow
State it is a huge huge huge life hack
for me and we actually have a special
offer for for listeners from Magic mind
all you need to do is go to magic
mind.co weird and use my discount code
at checkout weird to get a limited 20%
off your first order you guys know I
love it it's a new year it's a new you
go to magic mind.com
doco weird and use promo code weird
support the show support the brain get
into it big time and enjoy Joe G he's so
fun hope to see you on the road go to
YouTube you made it weird that's it get
into it you know I'm going to say
something hot off off the top here sure
I feel like okay so Joe brought me
brought us hopefully Katie if you want
one yeah you've always it's like people
this looks like we're on the search for
type three
diabetes like we're not satisfied I'm
here to tell you breaking news we found
it and it's seated next to you and it
was worth it worth it yes sir you have
type three diabetes no I have three
types of
diabetes you have diabetes one yeah you
have diabetes 2 but you also have
diabetes 3 which is completely different
completely yeah it's it actually cancels
out the first two it's a weird math
thing so two plus one the heel yeah
three heels one and two but it's
uncurable yeah I just think that um
first of all thank you so much you're
welcome what a great who else brings
gift a couple guests bring gifts and
it's always I don't come to a I don't
come to I'm a guest you don't come
empty-handed filthy Italian
I say filthy I ruin it you filthy almost
nice thank
you I appreciate it give me this
back it would be within your rights I
just wanted to acknowledge your
italianness and be funny so I added
filthy okay so I think um making
desserts with Oreo is a a little bit of
a cheat it is a little cheat a crumble
yeah you know what I mean they're like
oh Oreo cheesecake eat [__] dude you
can't sprinkle gold on money and be like
double money that's I never even thought
that you know what though but sometimes
have you ever had like an ingredient
that doesn't make sense at all sure yeah
what what do you mean I had a gummy bear
pudding I had a pudding that had like
gummy bears in it I like that and it was
weird it was like a kind of like one of
these mixed things you know what a
trifle is that's what Italians call them
too Trifles it's basically just a mix
Mish Moss of stuff it was when your
grandmother was poor and she just put
everything in a bowl lot of are poor
things yes that's right my favorite
dessert ice box cake My grandmother used
to make for birthday birthday ice box
cake she used to put it in the ice box
my everybody's birthday she used to do
it it's a make a cake Katie's nodding
you just put a cake in the freezer it's
a layer of I thought that just meant a
cake that you bought at the store that
was frozen oh no oh I didn't realize
this was going to be such an educational
podcast it is oh no we just shifted
genres so it it was there's it could be
any recipe but my grandma's recipe was
basically a gram cracker crust which is
important you know I mean I'm already
you're in that's also kind of the Oreo
cookie of the crust World well that's
right true your crust options though
what's that if you look at your crust
crust options I mean chopes I don't know
why Mr christophilis yeah so it's it's
it's it's the best it's the top no it's
great it's great top tier crust crust
layer of uh Jell-O layer of uh chocolate
pudding layer of Cool Whip yeah that's
it just boom bang bow that's like that
Food Network show it makes me sad though
the woman there's the name of it oh
welcome back it makes me sad though
today we're going to eat our feelings
it's not going to help it's not going to
help one of my Burns is it looks like
he's eating his feelings and apparently
his feelings are delicious you say it
about a big guy you can say about me uh
anyway uh what was I saying oh the show
on the Food Network where they it's like
on a budget MH everything on the Food
Network is like wine and you know like
Brian Regan says pre-portion s there's
like pistachios and it's very highend
and then there's one lady that's like
you can use Spam as toothpaste and
you're like
no she's like the fat from spam can be
used to clean
plaque it's so number one Defender
against plaque they don't want you to
know this but spam was originally oral
hygiene I talked to the other dentist
you know nine out of 10 on say try this
one guy he's got a lot of ideas he's
standing by lot of good ideas nobody's
talking to him four out of five be beer
pressured nope Samson dude you know
those test where they they draw a curved
line on a piece of paper yeah and then
they ask 10 people and they and the
first nine people are plants and the
last person is the person they're
studying and the first nine people say
it's a straight line and it's something
like 90% of the last people say it's a
straight line is it like a curve or is
it like a slight it's curved I think
it's slight slight okay but it's slight
wow but it's slight I say it again it's
slight Joe but it's slight curvature
okay yeah it's what we called a what was
the word a trifle a trifle all right so
we agree that Oreo is is this is
probably who who did that Oreo who made
the Oreo did it who put it in first
buddy time travel question okay you eat
an Oreo in 19 36
mhm I bet it tastes very different very
different in real things that's probably
real sugar yeah they probably went bad
yeah these Oreos have gone bad I know
but just eating them anyway right but I
bet you the
wafering I bet you I'll fix it I'll fix
it I bet you the wafer because I think
that's where a lot of the degradation
happens in the quality of the wafer the
quality of the cook it's a miracle but
we're putting like antifreeze in it to
keep it forever good and when you and I
are scav scavening scav Scavenging
Scavenging Scavenging yes we're
scavaging scavaging depends where we are
I love that you knew it you're such a I
was so excited to talk to you I'm going
to say hello after this
rip when we're Scavenging yeah did I say
it right Scavenging yeah scaven
Scavenging when we're going to be
scavengers is when we're scavengers yeah
it's a great Jim Gaffigan bit he's like
you ever been writing something and you
can't spell it so you just change it
he's like I'll see you tomorrow I'll see
you I'll see you next week that's funny
anyway when it's post-apocalyptic times
all this [__] I'm talking currently
about how Oreos now have antifreeze in
them I'll be humming a I'll be I'll be
humming a different tune because you
know took my tongue so I'll only be
humming a different oros trying to get
them I would you know that's got to be
the number one find of a scavenger
you're talking supermarkets will close a
year year and a half there's nothing
fresh around right everything's picked
through you come across a lone bag of
Oreo look at that you don't need
anything to open it it's already sealed
like you don't need like a can you Canal
it the new ones you can read some you
can sa which is perfect for
post-apocalypse yeah cuz you don't want
yourself to
spoil they can't no but to give the
illusion that they might you can reeal
them they're fresh yeah a fresh Oreo uh
or a Betty Crocker tub of
frosting yeah but I feel like that would
get hard right yeah it comes out like
like a sand
castle can't take a bite out of the
brick everybody happy birthday Timmy but
that's good in POS apocalyptic you have
a brick of something oh of course you
want you want to St all a brick form
it's easy to travel
with guys the future is
Brick everything's going to be brick I'm
a Zombie I'm out let me ask you this Joe
Tris kit you was a zombie oh no the
investor was a zombie I'm a Zombie I
want people to die I am out yeah I eat
them as carry on I just wanted to use
the word carryon Triscuits or wheat
thins um I'm not an animal I mean we
thin I don't like chew on Hay a Triscuit
is terrible the person who came up with
a Triscuit a tret put that in your
basket it's terrible a Triscuit trisuit
so worse you can't sounds like a
medieval torture put him in the Triscuit
he'll talk you know when you go to like
an old timey Torture Museum and you're
like oh my God an iron maiden and then
there's just a box of trisuit it looks
like it too if you look at the weave the
way it's weaved a bed of Triscuit I
would talk if I'm laying on a bed of
Triscuit for a week I would s you
anything I'll tell you where the King's
at that's a new expression I feel like
I've been sleeping on a bed of
Triscuit is such a funny way to say you
had a low thread
count I pulled the Triscuits up they
were scratchy the thread count was so
low the Sheets Were Triscuits you know
what has the the thing with me was the
Triscuit is it's very a Shredded Wheat
like a cereal not the Frosted not the
fun time speak about [__] Love A Min
you can't go full I was going to say oh
you go full one you put one in a bowl
and
it's it's Titanic out the fure is Brick
form think of the shredded wheat not the
mini the big walr mustache that you put
in the bowl and you just think before
the milk's on there you really just
think about where your life went wrong
that you're about to eat a Brillo pad it
hangs out the bowl like a uncooked
spaghetti you know is UN spaghetti it's
a Ramen brick it it another brick form
that'll be good in postapocalyptic the
post-apocalyptic is Brick I think we
found it out aaca brick wow t-shirt
t-shirt but it has it's
tattered everybody likes things cut now
like the
jeans wait we do now we're on taste buds
you realiz we I didn't realize turns out
any of the Staten Island and practical
jokers get them and talk them about food
you'll have yourself a h you're done
it's it's because I I I find I don't
know it's a slight of me but always
people like to talk to me about food is
that right I get talked about I think
people just like to talk to you cuz okay
here's my hello when I saw you at the
store is when we met it was great and I
was just like I love this guy
[Laughter]
well I completely Fang girl I completely
well that was nice but that wasn't it it
was nice that you said nice things uh
but it was also nice like the vibe in
the back of the comedy store isn't
always look at you you look like a you
look like a kind Muppet you know what I
mean this is a night like you're just
kind
of face yeah nice they're just holding
you like that just see that's where I'm
at people like talking to me about food
they
do this is great stud you happier um no
I I try to be kind yeah I have a muppet
face you don't really I don't mean that
you have a muppet face I'm very animated
face yeah good good comedy face yes a
good com it's a good face for that kid
has got a good face for comedy I don't
know he looks like he's got comedy face
dude you ever meet someone who has
comedy face and they're not funny I was
going to say and they're not doing
comedy what I I like that yeah and yes
yeah I've met someone with full comedy
body and you're like Jesus what I would
do in that thing yeah it's like they
don't know how to ride a standard you
want to possess them yeah I would love
to possess you and flail about get a
Freaky Friday situation just give me a
week yeah dude don't get me started on
the real life if we ever figure out
Freaky Friday you know what's going to
happen the ultra Rich are going to want
to buy the bodies of this is too dark
but they'll go to like a family that
needs a break and be like let me like
like weird Norman Rockefeller give me a
body and they'll swap
with like a healthy 18-year-old who will
take a hit he'll be in an old ass body
isn't that [__] up yeah will be yeah I
hope we'll never figure it out I don't I
think we can you think we will you and
I here in the lab right in the left
let's the other one I wrote a movie
about this the other one was people will
hire people to swap with them like I
could swap with Kumil hid work out for
me and then swap back wow like take
someone who has the will yes to work out
yes and then I just go into a deep
freeze for 3 months oh that'd be amazing
come out and I'm like but does do come
out all just yeah he's well does he get
out of shape that's the mve I don't mind
sharing this cuz what are you gonna
[__] steal it what are you going to
steal it are you hey there's a writer
back there the strike's
over season
out you can find them by the ding of
their tyrer use laptops
stop using well I swap with Kumil so
he's in my body I'm in his body but I
just go into a freeze cuz for safety
reasons oh of course because it's you're
get preserved so he's in my body but
then he uh in the movie he goes donut
which means he doesn't want to work out
he just wants to be a fun fat guy and
then he goes on the on the Lamb on the
lamb in your body then they wake me up
in kum's body oh that's fun we have to
find him are we making it I got like
that one's you can't steal it get be
stolen it's already uh Wheels on the
tarmac baby but I don't know there I you
have you have you just did a movie yeah
impractical jok Jer movie well not just
but yeah I did that one just to me to
you too to just well you just watched it
you guys just got around to it just to
me it was 2004 that was it really no
when was it no
200 well it debuted 3 days before uh
February of 2020 right before the world
shutdown we were the longest running
movie in theater because all the movie
theaters shut down and we were on the
billboard we were on the Marquee all the
movies nobody can see it yeah we played
for like 3 weeks so it was like February
I think we came out February 15th 20
something like that Fe mid-February 2020
how did it do CU I know you guys great
it did great we did great people did
come out they did a limited release for
the first weekend against our wishes
being like guys everybody's going to
come see it they're like well we have to
Pro it crushed and then we went for a
wide release we had two weeks wide
release and everything shut down and it
was doing great in the wide release it
was doing well yeah yeah it was doing
well it was I'm going to say it that's
the worst thing about Co I I think I I
would agree I would agree science agrees
you have charts they go impr practical
jokers was robbed of its box office yeah
number two death horrible statistics
that's it yeah the box office Rob yeah
but I write I'm uh I want to grow when I
grew up I'm want to be a WR director
that's why I got into this whole thing
years ago yeah that's what I'm after but
you want to direct yeah direct is that
right yeah 100% I bet you'd be great
thank you yeah yeah I script that I'm
doing and stuff too and yeah I have a
body swap movie I I love to direct it I
love Camille too isn't he great yeah
yeah he said he didn't want to do movies
that hinge on his body ah I was like I
get it yeah for sure we don't have that
problem no when I say we using the Royal
Wii I don't have no no no there's Kum at
the top of the mountain and then there's
the Wii is the triangle beneath him all
of us well Ryan Reynolds is up there too
I guess all these buff [__]
yeah I hate when they're buff and funny
though that really hurts like keep the
funny for the fat ones keep the funny
for the fat ones yeah I think that's I
think that's I get a little possessive
we're over here yeah of our food and our
funny I know cuz I can't be goodlooking
right you know you could learn to you
can't learn to be good-looking could
learn to be funny but it is sort of
brilliant that's that's like the
million-dollar man where you're like
what if we take someone who's
good-looking and can become buff and
then and they're all funny like teach
them like like the way they teach the Al
Lama like you get a kid and teach him
everything that's what they did with
Ryan Reynold they like okay boner a lot
boner is a big one people love the bone
Hardon is out people don't know what you
mean when you say Hardon boner sounds
funnier boner is funny it's a bone it's
not a bone is it it's just blood and and
jizz I we don't know it's science we're
not scientists a boner is disgusting
yeah it's weird isn't it a boner vagina
it sorry Katie but it is I don't even
know how we got here I don't know how we
got here Ryan Reynolds was being taught
by the do I saw him in an orange robe
like the dolly llama as a child and
they're going boner boner boner boner
funny word and then I took it to boners
are gross cuz they are they're like
water balloons and it's disgusting but
like Carter water balloons yeah and it's
when where water balloon is the boner of
the of the summer activities yes yeah
that's true when you're a kid a water
balloon is as exciting as a boner it's
over it's like game over what are we
doing now I'll go take a nap and you
don't even know why you liked it you're
like
ah clean up but what I oh where does the
BL when a
boner fills with blood I know no one
wants to think about it but that I
remember my including me including me
buddy I have to get one I have to get
one and I'm like ah there it is you have
to get one I have to get one I have to
get one I have to get
one who's forcing you to get bonus I
have to do you need help BL twice I have
to get
one be well at least nighttime nighttime
emissions oh no God the worst thing to
say nighttime emissions is a great punk
band name I know that gets used a lot as
a joke okay but can you imagine being
called nighttime emissions yeah I like
that except it does sort of sound like
farts anyway where did the blood come
from like what yeah what's losing it
probably your brain people are saying
that is that it i r in the streets
that's what I told they say that stops
you start thinking with the wrong part
of your body yeah I've heard so there's
science behind that like you were
thinking with the wrong head cuz the
blood had to come from somewhere right
I've heard the same thing when you eat
you know how in a writer's room everyone
eats [__] 9 foot party subs and then
they suck the rest of the day it's cuz
all the blood that was in their brain
went to digest their food I've hurt that
does that kind of makes sense I mean
yeah I said it with confidence but when
you that that's all it takes I've heard
in my whole life and I believed it
that's all I'll say I can't I don't have
the data you don't have you're the data
you have is up here the data I have is
anecdotal I guess you could say it might
have been from an episode of Hawaii 5 it
was which is which is that's it it's
truth it's real yeah go on book them do
you were G to I would say uh getting
flush is the same thing right blood face
like when you get nervous or when you
when you get embarrassed I think and I
think that's the same amount of blood
that it takes to put in the wiener boner
not me you don't think so I'd have to be
red like the Kool-Aid name to get all
that
blood oh I get it I see you did
big old dingdong it's a big old dingdong
riff big old dingdong uh it's that's
interesting so a flush is the same
amount blood rushing your so if I FL is
a bon face you got boner face you have
boner face you have a boner face you got
Bon you got bonafied boner face blushing
is the boner of the face which is
something that would make you blush
giving you double boner face then the
blood doesn't know where to go inside
it's like just running around all over
the place can you get a boner and be
blush blush at the same time let me
try give me a minute hold
on
nope well you the blushing is covered
cuz you're embarrassed that you're
trying to get a boner on the podcast so
you do get flesh oh no I I just couldn't
get a boner you were starting with the
boner were like get the get embarrassed
then embarrass me I tried then embarrass
me do you embarrass EAS you don't seem
like you do no yeah I don't have a shame
Jean really I don't I always made people
laugh that way and I always had to put
myself out there like that I I honestly
remember the the last time I was
embarrassed I think it was like a thing
from your childhood when you grew up my
sister Carla my middle sister she was
always went through that phase where we
like you know didn't like each other she
a couple years older than me and it was
Easter Sunday at bellita restaurant
bellita 2 in Staten Island Bita 2 I only
Chinese restaurants did that no they did
this is the sequel to was by St on mall
and it was back in the day when wall by
the mall there's a mall in Staten Island
we're going to build the wall people
keep coming out of Staten Island we're
going to keep Brooklyn out Staten Island
makes Brooklyn takes I don't know why
I'm doing this don't NE like it though
we like it I do so it was back in the
day when they had it was smoking in
restaurants I'm like 10 years old 12
years old they have smok in in
restaurants so they do do you remember
when they did this I don't know but they
if they didn't that now they would just
be a glass door inside the restaurant
and all the smokers would ins eat inside
the glass door yeah exactly like a place
for yeah steam room a great place for a
murder like a hand the glass slides and
then stand on Italian restaurants it it
worked Dual Purpose we'll get back to
that is that real is that was that a
thing in your childhood where you were
like lot of nicknames I had a lot of I
had a lot of uncles that had nicknames
for show really yeah and I had a couple
I had a real Uncle who was kind of we'll
get into that too if you like but um my
I was walking out of the SM so scared
don't tell your uncle I'm I'm a loud
mouth you're fine you're fine he didn't
have any children so when you walk like
you see like there's a little step right
here like a just a kind of small step so
when you walked out of the smoking room
there was this little step and I had to
go to the bathroom so my sister was
coming with me and I fell into the
restaurant the restaurant was packed
Easter Sunday Staten Island forget it
place was you know standard room only
and I hit the floor like loud and the
whole place like went like ooh and like
and my sister stood above me was like ha
like a real like Lucy and you know
Charlie Brown yeah so I and then I just
jumped up and went Tada and everybody
laughed and I was was like oh that's
when you got the I I I remember that as
a vivid core memory and I kind of was
like oh I don't have to be embarrassed
you you turn it around are wow I always
want comedians to tell me things like
that and they never do because I'm
always just asking them about we we Tris
gets and bonus we've been all over the
map here but you just offered that I did
want to say where is that blood there's
a loose patch of blood going around all
our bodies it could be a blush it could
be a boner could be a minr that's right
but then it's out that's the exit sh
that's how it wants to leave but you
know like Seinfeld's the puppet the sock
puppet that wants to escape through the
dryer you really don't want to stay you
want to stay you want to you don't want
to be loose blood you don't want to see
what they do with loose blood out there
on the street stay in here stay with
your people stay in the house stay in
the house it's for your own good lock
the door [__] you mom going out the air
lock that's a vagina you [__] idiot
goodbye yeah mhm don't go with the
lining
this is what Osmosis Jones should have
been oh that's right should have been a
lady it could have been a whole other
way different story things coming in
things going out it's like a library
check in check out who knows
osmosis well Jones could be Osmosis
Jones
Diary osmosis Jones's
Diary wow this is fun this is fun we're
already having a lot of fun F uh but we
were you fell and you said Tada yeah I
just have so many feelings about that
just I
mean I just relate you know what I mean
I remember being in junior high and
we're about to start seventh grade which
felt like the real thing right they were
like the rulers of the school the
seventh and eighth grade and me and my
friend ER we were having a sleepover
same bed deal with it yeah back in the
day there's no there's no Blurred Lines
now I feel kids get their own bedroom
there's towels oh my God sleeping bags
sauna massage good night chocolate on
the pillow what kind of candle do you
want back in the day it's like getting
Peters B yeah getting Peters bad the
parents woke up at 12:30 the next day
you were up at 8 like trying to scab
that's why I know what trisuit say it's
crazy me so we're in bed and we're
quizzing each other and I go I was
obsessed with that moments like that I
was like let's say you fall in the
hallway my joke was yell medic which I
didn't even know that that's like a
that's like a war thing War thing yeah
but I just was like I had read it in
bloom County and you did Tada yeah and
it killed and you got the the rush of
and then you were hooked yeah right or
were it wasn't no not really it but it
was more like that I didn't have to feel
that feeling and I could turn it into
something yeah so I think that but then
when I got into high school I was
getting bullied a little bit I was on
the you know I was a math team guy I was
on the ma I was a mathlete you know
and bowling team I was a bowler yeah
yeah so I was a real catch and bowling
yeah so there was this thing I went to
all booy Catholic school with the boys
that's how I you know we met at freshman
year in high school so we uh I did this
I had this weird thing I was like kind
of getting bullied and there was this
one football player and then just one
day I remember we're in this like
passway like in the they called it the
link area it was between two different
wings of the high school and I just
knocked the books out of his hands the
bul yeah and I said pick them pick them
up and he goes I'm sorry Mr G it was
like a bit and it was funny and then
like he it became this reverse bullying
thing where I like made him give me
piggybacks to to class like it was
really funny and everybody just did it
yeah it was really you went into the
dragon lir and did bits yeah I did bits
yeah wouldn't it be funny if I you
pretended to slay me this is be great
here stab me um wait why did he I need
more let's tell me what was the flavor
of the bullying of this guy cuz this is
needs to be documented I think he was
down he was a good guy down deep and it
wasn't even it wasn't even really like
he wasn't one of the main ones it was
kind of just more of a like if you
weren't a jock and you were that I
remember this in the smart kind of
things like that you've seen all the
movies all the but I remember it I
remember the kids being like I just
don't know what I am and they were like
lower lower tier bullies there was like
the head honchos running the streets and
then there were guys like me that didn't
know are we are we are we the bullied
and then there were the bullies going
like are we bullies and so he was just
kind of like it was kind of just like
you know I think when you're growing up
too that I mean especially guys 14 to 17
you're getting your your personality
you're getting your handle on your humor
your wit is quicker than your conscience
you know you're just saying stuff and
it's not you don't even me there's not a
lot of intent behind a lot of it and
then it's being received on the other
end in a way that as you were growing up
being like am I is that true you know so
it's a little it was a little weird but
it was just like it became a thing and I
just remember he was a great guy and we
just you know but the first time you did
it weren't you nervous there's the guy
who kind of bullies you and you knock
the books out of his hand yeah and
you're like he'll get that I'm J he'll
get a joke yeah because he was also way
bigger than me like I was like 102 lbs
you know like soak and wet with Nickel
in my pockets like I was just you know
not a big kid at all and he was like he
was like I think it was like a
linebacker or something he was like one
of the football players and and it just
like I had had him I had like a math I
had like a math class with him too and
we had kind of just like it wasn't
always like that so I figured I'm a
gambler too so I was like you know what
that's why you had the in
your so you I just it's it's a lot to
ask I really am fascinated by the story
I'm not just trying to milk it it's like
knocking someone's book out of their
hand you could you could knock my book
out of my hand if I was holding a book
and there would still be a part of me
that would have to practice restraint
even though I knew you were 100% joking
cuz there's just something it's like
it's the being pantsed of the book
holding world that's right it's a same
exactly and there's like a shame and
there's like a and it's loud so like you
really put it out I did put it out there
it did yeah and he really are you still
friends with this guy uh no not because
I don't just because I'm not friends
with people from high school anymore
nothing against I was friendly with him
throughout and stuff but then we both
went way to college and you know life
happens and stuff but you comment on uh
if you would I or or correct me I feel
like New York
City I don't know the way it is the kids
growing up faster becoming Savvy being a
little bit more
independent uh riding the subway like I
was just in this and it's like you see
seven-year-olds on the train and you're
like what the [__] but it's fine as an
outsider I'm I'm shocked by it now but
uh and as a parent but like I feel like
the growing up faster and the the
loudness I always tell people I've said
this a million times on the show it's
like in New York you have to be kind of
rude to be polite like if you if you if
someone ask you what sandwich you want
you're in a long line and you're like
what's your favorite sandwich like
you're actually [__] everything up
you just have to say like turkey Swiss
that's the way to do it so I feel like
that whole environment shakes the kids
up and I'm I'm this is a long way to say
is bullying worse in New York
City it seems like it is like Halloween
yeah oh hallow Halloween in New York get
out Hat Halloween I lived in the wrong
neighborhood for a white kid growing up
to be Halloween I was on the other side
of the tracks of mariners Harbor you
just get jumped oh man I hated it yeah
is that what it was oh my God it was
terrible yeah was terrible I I had I had
I in my neighborhood I only had like one
or two uh White friends everybody else I
lived right by the projects in my
neighborhood and I had uh you know when
it was like that like I remember my good
one of my best friends still his name's
Jason Joseph always looked out for me
great guy year younger than me he fell
in with a crowd and uh I remember like
one vividly I was like 13 years old and
we were going to go like you know
shaving cream whatever and I was walking
down the I was like coming out of my
house and he was walking down the street
and he yelled and he just yelled down
the street he like like Joe and I look
and he goes go back inside and I was
like okay and then I remember just a
group of like just hoodlums around the
neighborhood just a mix of the bad kids
in the neighborhood was like coming
around and he was just you know throwing
eggs and like like bad like th they took
a garbage can and threw it like out a
car and like like bad and he like gave
me a heads up to like get back inside
get back in the house and I remember one
of my other friends didn't like he
wasn't friendly with them or whatever
and I just maybe 20 minutes later saw
him running down the street just like K
chasing yeah yeah just throwing exit
over and stuff yeah like that candy it
was it was like bad so I was like I
always and like that made me hate
Halloween like I hate Halloween and my
wife my wife loves loves it and like my
kids are all into it now when you get
kids it gets reinvented you know yeah so
now I just go and beat up children in
the streets to make it nostalgic just a
throwback awkward you to fall back in
love with it you know is that a good
costume or did you run into the wrong
element on the street like are you do
you have needs careful or is that a
squirt function that you're is there
some sort of pump your squeeze in your
hand or is that natural just natural is
that the blood that you could have
blushed or had a boner that's your you
can't and now you can't you do have
extra blood sorry I'm really fascinated
by this but here's the other thing when
you give blood they give you orange
juice it turns into blood I don't get
that everything I think water turns into
blood how are we making blood Jo yes and
how does it know when to stop it's like
an autofilling pool yeah you know they
have that function it's just like how
does it know the pool's full you a fill
in pool you're doing a r for yourself
all right nice I still use a garden hose
really God bless you is it above ground
St Island
side it's what a girlfriend Cannonball
from the top no you know they used to do
the fake in theg grounds like I had an
uncle who did like the overground pool
but he put a deck around it was like you
had to get into the pool that's good
great very goodart what what do you go
back to Staten Island I have family
that's still there I don't go there as
much my mom lived there for a while but
after she passed I didn't really I
didn't go there much I have just an
uncle and a bunch of cousins that I'm
close with but I don't really see that
much do you like it it's I'll open it
with this I have a hard time going back
to Boston not because of Boston like if
Katie was like I'm going to go to Boston
I'd be like you're going to have a great
time yeah but when I go to Boston I get
like I just start to feel the walls
closing in on me because everywhere I
look is a memory of being a child like
you being chased not literally Halloween
but those feelings of just being like I
remember being a kid and being like God
damn I can't wait to be grown I just
can't wait to have a car and a wallet
yeah I didn't know this at the time but
like a phone I want keys to an apartment
I want to get the [__] I want to do what
I want and like I go back and I
just I start getting claustrophobic just
because of the memories do you how do
you feel going back I don't feel like
it's same place I grew up at all because
it's like I think it's totally changed
like it was very neighborhoody you know
like everybody had yard it was like all
that kind of stuff and it's just very
different Staten Island you know not
anymore what happened to The Yards well
like for instance the house that my my
mom sold our house we had the biggest
house on the Block next to my next door
neighbors uh we were a corner lot um on
Harbor Road and my when my mom sold the
house they they knocked the house down
and put six tow houses on it who and
like one of those like they just made
everything tow houses and stand now like
it's just all very everybody's on top of
each other one house is now six houses
yeah one lot has like six town houses
you know those ones that connected
together tach one of those and then like
they made the dead end on my street
where we all used to play they made it a
cut through now they broke the street
through so it's like it just like a
really weird it's like a weird thing
like when I go there it's not I remember
we were driving to my sister's house in
Jersey my daughter who was three at the
time we had to go through satin Island
and I was like hey you want to go see
where daddy used to live and she's like
yeah and we drove by and I was like I
said this used to be this rolling up the
window I'm good dad get back on the
express way but it was like it was like
this used to be this like you have to
say that like this used to be there this
used to to be there so I don't really
feel that same connection with my
neighborhood why does it get such [__]
I've never my father and I when we would
go to the city would go to saen Island
and take the fery and I didn't remember
being like what a [__] hell hole
let's get out of here but it I but then
I get to New York and I started doing
comedy that's where I learned that saden
Island sucks is and I'm not saying it
does but I heard it had the dump forever
it had the it was where all the garbage
was the dump was there for the whole
city D hard where did the dump go it's
still there the middle the park they
just grew grass on top of it they made
it a trifle they made it a garbage
trifle it's like come take your kids
down the garbage trifle Park oh my God
dirt on it yeah okay so but you can't
see it no not anymore you can't see it
can't smell it anymore either cuz that
was a big to be able to smell it in
August woof you don't want that no that
stch coming across the
Zano yeah it was bad sorry my Italian
showed uh what's buah that's a type of
mozzarella what is that no it's
Buffalo smell like
B
yeah okay so you fell and you did ta and
you're Italian you just recapping know
for those who are just tuning in
sometimes yeah it's a radio show people
just turned it on full of points I'm
wondering where the and I know you meet
the boys freshman year of high school
yeah but when did your bowling you're
mathing when did you start going like
help me understand what your
relationship to Comedy was when you were
little and when you started to see it
crystallizing into something that you
could do always loved comedy always
watched what my father and laughed and
like always had a like around the house
like to be a little silly never had the
nerve to Take It Outside The Family yeah
really but in the house I was kind of
very funny and didn't mind doing stuff
like I remember my dad and I used to
watch uh home improvement with Tim Allen
and Tim Allen was my first comedy
special I remember watching with my
father I was like H whatever yeah and it
was that one with the you know that one
like this classic one so I was like I
remember seeing that I was like oh this
was fun but then we also watched like
Richard Jenny and like my dad really
liked like standup comedy but we he
always liked comedy films I grew up on
film Mel Brooks is my hero like comedy
film comedy movies I think that's why I
want being director yeah yeah yeah edit
that out I just don't want to help in
anyway it's just be you should you just
be every time I want to be
direct what did he say what is he saying
we just talking about boners for 30
minutes like this kid got it thanks for
having me on I don't want to help your
career in any way I just want a long
tape of you talking about boners and
loose blood the free range blood that
can do anything so you want to be a
director because of Mel Brooks is so
your dad liked being a silly bean hey he
was not he was my mom and dad were two
different types my dad was like the qu
he was 63 big big guy but he was super
quiet but he had like that thing where
you could just say something loud enough
that just one person would hear it and
then when they laugh you like what are
you laughing at like one of those like
it was great super dry my mother was a
flip of that my mother was walked in her
room eyes on her crazy like batet crazy
lot of fun high energy and so my mother
always said I was the mix of the two of
them you know so I have a little bit of
both of that um and I was like I didn't
I always made my friends laugh um I
really attributed really to mostly Sal
volcano because we were at lunch and I
used to always make him laugh the taste
bud uh yeah the taste bud you might know
him friend of joar Roa uh or Christ
stano depends what you watch no press
Network check it out I only watch here I
only watched the s on yeah no I'm just
kidding I just my dear friend it's so
funny um so they uh so we I used to make
I sat with a bunch of guys but S I used
to make laugh very hard and throughout
our whole friendship and I always done
that and he joined the Improv Club at
school and he's like Joe you got to come
you got to come do it you got to come do
it it was junior year and I was like I
don't know in front of people I had
those friends too like you got to do it
I always was waiting for like an
invitation you know what I mean like
like it felt like for other people this
this is going to seem forced but like
driving in Manhattan like I remember
when I realized those are the same jerks
and idiots that are driving everywhere
yeah you know what I mean but you think
you need a golden you you might in the
coming years they're making like a tax
even to drive anyway but what I'm saying
is like the Improv team when I'm in high
school I was like I can't do that and
then you have friends that go like we
should do that so but you see people
that also do that and you're like oh no
but you don't realize that improv was
such a supportive like there the whole
thing right yes and at its core is super
supportive by Nature it's different than
like stand up or anything it was that
style it was that style yeah because not
every impr some improv places you come
in and and there a little light on that
theory and they're just kind of like
what what is
this so you're just doing like bad we
did games but in he did he did scene
work too the teacher which was good and
then in the scene work is really where
like you got to see people's like just
go quick fire and stuff and my mind
always worked quick yeah and I was just
I still remember the first scene I ever
did and I was just like I remember it
crushed and I was like what was it I was
I was I was with another friend of mine
in it and uh so we're in old boy school
and they invite the all our sister
schools to come so it's a co-ed thing
and it's uh 40 girls and 40 guys doing
the doing the Improv and Sor was 80
people on The Improv he he just filled
it was just it was like an activity it
was every Thursday night everybody could
come to like an open forum and then he
would weed out and put up on improv show
with 20 people that got picked 10 girls
10 guys um so we were doing a seene and
it was my first one weed out yeah he
weed them out when you're one of the
weeds cuz a lot of them were not I mean
I mean people do think they're funny but
they're not good at improv different to
right no it's completely fair so he said
uh you know the scene was I had to get
out of this date I was on and I was on a
date with one of the girls and the my
motivation was to get out of the date
and the waiter's motivation was to keep
me there as long as he could and I
remember going back and forth and just
like making up all the excuses and
nothing's working and then eventually I
just I said oh sorry I took off my shoe
I said I got to take this yeah and like
like get smart I was like oh they need
me I was like I'm I got to go and I was
like everybody lost it and it was just
like stupid and funny and I was like and
everybody laughed in the room and I was
like oh wow this is fun and then I just
the rest was just I just did improv and
made people laugh and I think it really
just helped me just socially and not be
as awkward of course you reminded me
when I was in my high school improv team
my taada moment my friend Adam Jetty
looking back it was kind of telling
we're in a scene we're on a bus and he
comes up and he goes roses are red
violets are blue he's making a big
choice and I went can I sit down here
here with you like I just interrupted
him and it
murdered but the poor guy was like no
rose is like he had his own idea I had
to finish it yeah yeah it's very telling
there's a part of me that wanted to be
like sh yeah I know I wasn't going to
wait for your poem Adam I'm sorry but
doing doing the Improv with like guys
that are your friends are different too
like so me and the boys were friends we
leave go to college we come back and M
and was like hey he did George CH he's
like I going to start this improv comedy
TR you guys want to do it with me we
like sure so we start doing improv we
start practicing improv four of us in my
basement in my mother's basement I was
living my mother at the time in my
mother's basement and it was just like
for six months just watching tapes of
ourselves for no reason just because we
were enjoying it we all had jobs and
then when you do your friends I remember
like just the support because then I
moved out to LA in 03 and I did improv
Olympic out here yeah and I did oh did I
did in Chicago okay yeah so I did it
with like but I did it with strangers
and this was my first time improvising
with strangers I remember improvising
with your friends like it's different
like you feel like they could just let
you go and I remember specifically there
was this one scene so I used to come
back and forth between New York and here
for two years and whenever I came back
to New York we put on a show because I'd
be in town it'd be fun to do it you know
so I remember I had gone from a show in
improv Olympic and it was just like a
weird show where I wasn't feeling
supported and then I go to New York to
do a show with the boys The Tenderloins
our group and we're doing a show and the
the stage cleared and I just sat down
like nobody was there like we just did a
big funny scene I just sat down and I
just sat there and nobody was saying
anything so I just opened up a fake book
and went dear diary Chad looked great
today and like it crushed and then they
all just had the faith just to stand
there and just let me go where like I
felt like whenever you did it like in LA
or wherever else with strangers they
were like oh like get out of here and
they just sat there and like watch and
it was one of it felt like so weird and
different I remember that moment being
like this is the difference between
doing comedy with people that care about
you and your friends versus people who
you don't know just trying to shine
trying to shine being like and I equate
that to being like if you tried to cast
impr practical jokers versus do the show
with people who are truly friends it's a
totally different idea yeah yeah it
wouldn't work it wouldn't yeah so that's
why I I really think like a big part of
my comedy was always it was always
camaraderie it was always uh
collaborative you know and now that I'm
out on my own it's like it was a to that
was the biggest curve for me biggest
learning curve for me was like oh this
is go ahead and I'm like me kind of it's
it's a big it was a big change for a
while you know I've gotten used to it
but that was the biggest going into
stand up stand up comedy yeah yeah when
did that start uh
20021 right really recently 21 yeah my
first show was in January in Appleton
Wisconsin 2021 the skyline uh yeah yeah
good choice yeah yeah me Steve Burn and
Jiggy did a show there yeah Will
Smith yeah he that guy doesn't like
jokes he's not a big fan of the jokes we
did uh his name is markk jagaran he's a
he's a very funny comic who's a friend
of mine and a very good standup so he
helped me like I was kind of nervous
getting out there for the first time so
why no not why nervous why'd you do it
why'd you do it Joe uh I had some things
in my personal life that had me have to
leave the show and I still had to like
pay bills and do things leave practical
jokers oh this is news to me I'm not
just being a good interviewer I didn't
know that I'm being a bad researcher you
don't need to do research you don't talk
about that we don't not really yeah what
happened was it in the group was it in
the group like tensions in the group oh
was something in your personal life
personal life my wife and I separated
for a while well that's on your
Wikipedia yeah got that so you couldn't
you couldn't connect a and
b you know your wife and you separate
that's when you stay with the show like
nobody's like ah my life's falling apart
time to leave my show yeah you got to be
in a different space Oh you were just
bummed yeah so was like a lot it was
just like a lot going on but then you
got back yes we're back what happened we
decided to keep another so but I just
mean not just for gossip it's like
interesting obviously I was just joking
last night cuz I've been married twice
and somebody was like oh Pete you've
been married before too and I was like
yeah tal like I made the joke that we
got divorced got back and those those
have always been interesting to me so in
the spirit of helpfulness what helped
what healed between not not the dirt not
the stuff she wouldn't want you to say
of course but for people that are like
no I think getting paw what how do you
do that right accountability of yourself
I think think take a real look in the
mirror you know self be hard on yourself
be hard on yourself and it's no way way
easier to be harder than when you're
literally by yourself and separated like
you know like that was a big thing being
separated like I have I I realized this
when I separated from when I was in my
apartment I had never lived by myself
ever in my life that's see that's and I
was 47 years old and like that apartment
gets quiet so this was three years in
the future you look
great um yeah that is a big one cuz when
I was married the first time I had never
lived alone gotcha and why did yours
fall apart she had an affair got it but
really that's not it that was the um
that was like
the I guess the symptoms were all these
things that I didn't even know I didn't
know 100% was a little baby boy got Mar
when I was 22 so like oh okay so when we
split up and then I was alone I started
like this is so stupid women are so much
more than doing dishes it's not about
doing dishes but it is about going like
what if they weren't weren't here like
you got to know how to keep your house
make your bed figure out
dinner that's not my I still do those
things I may this is important because
I'm not saying those are what wives are
for I made my daughter breakfast this
morning and I made her lunch we [__]
do it we [__] do it but one of the
ways I learned how to do that was when
you're alone you see how much goes into
it and I had a mommy wife and that's
embarrassing to say but that's not what
she wanted to be and I kind of
without knowing what I was doing I'm
trying to I'm embarrassed so I'm trying
to say like I didn't know right but I
was going like you you take care of the
things and I'll go out and like tap
dance and do stand up and I got to pay
for all this like you think you know you
think about like what what it really
means to contribute to a relationship
and that was a big thing for me it was
like I was like I'm out here killing
myself trying to Prov to provide and
she's like yeah but you're not providing
what what's needed that's it but that's
okay look I I don't want to say we're
victims but in a sense we are because we
inherited let's let's remove victims
that's too hot what I'm saying is I
sympathize with what you're saying
because I also grew up in a house where
it was just very very unspoken dad pays
for everything so dad's vote counts for
like five votes and I catch myself
sometimes doing that with Val she um
great example I think I'm going to be
shooting a movie in December I'll be
gone for like 20 days and
nobody no Val's very supportive she's
not I'm not afraid to tell her that I do
you know is that how's that sound how's
that look that month all that sort of
stuff but because I get paid to do it
you're just sort of like it's tempting
to be like so therefore no one can say
[__] Yeah and then she Val also wants to
be a director uh and she is taking wants
to take a course like a a directing
course and there's these things and you
make your own films and you learn
shotless and all this stuff and it was
like something like 30 days and every
day from 9: to 5 and she pitches this to
me and if I'm being honest and it's
embarrassing there was a little
resistance I was like 30 days is a long
[__] time for me to make every meal
and pick up every pickup and and I now I
can't work and all all these feelings
and and the the the fail safe thing it's
like a train track and it's always set
to this way meaning money
wins and then I was like and now to
really overshare but I'm going to put
this back to you when I go home and
visit my parents I see the cost of my
mother not having fulfilled certain
things that she would have and I come
home that conversation was very positive
I was like you you have to do it but we
uncovered that I was a little slow to
say that because I was like but that
will cost money that's 30 days and
you're gone and you come home and
there's less money right but that's not
valid and then when I go home to see my
parents and my mom is just like I just
wish I was good at something and I'm
like I run home and I kiss Val's feet
metaphorically that I'm like go [__]
do it it doesn't work it doesn't work
just me bringing home bags of bacon
doesn't doesn't work for me it doesn't
work for you what does that make you
think I just talk for a long time I'm
going to eat a
ter everything's
fine no I I I do think I I do think well
I had my daughter right before Co
started my daughter I came home and she
said to me she goes daddy you're home I
love when you come to visit shut the
[__] so shut the [__] up what the [__]
is going on like what is that it's
hysterical and it hurts no I'm I'm with
you on every like my 5-year-old daughter
says that to me so and then it cuts the
black and goes Magnolia pictures present
it's like an IFC movie so that happens
you know but it's not even just like you
can't just play it it's more just like a
mindset and also like paying attention
to what like I always say people say oh
what's what's the secret to like a
marriage and blah blah advice and I
always say no matter if you feel like
your soulmates are not know it's
impossible to know what other people are
thinking you need to say what you're
thinking say what you need say what
you're talking about because I always
thought I knew best she always thought
she knew best she always thought uh you
know we all had our roles and whatnot
and it just turns into this no you're
both completely off and before you know
it and you look at it you're like we are
so far away from and nobody even knows
what anybody's really thinking 100% yeah
that is okay I want to we're going to
stay on all of this but like Val's not a
comedian and one of the things that I've
noticed rubbing off on her she's getting
more comfortable saying what she's
actually thinking like even making jokes
and I was like see that's that's
practice like making a joke like oh yeah
cuz Katie didn't want a pudding that's a
dumb joke I'm that's sarcasm I'm not a
huge fan of that but like yeah we can
get practice at reporting in real time
what we're thinking and feeling which is
a huge skill I think it's I think it's
probably one of the best like people I
I'm known for really saying like
shooting straight like you know if I
have something to say I I'll say it you
know that kind of thing but when it came
to certain things I'd be I would assume
that either she knew or didn't want to
say it because I knew the Fallout and I
was leaving to go do this thing in two
days and I'll be gone for six like so
like I want to make these moments at
home vacation home it was like a you you
make this like fake reality like my my
job costs a lot of travel and now even
that I travel so much I'm still like dro
the kid off at school do this do
homework at 3:00 I could do all these
different things it's just a different
way to do it you know you manage your
time you're in your own you're you're
Your Own Boss you're not part of like a
whole machine you know like you could do
what you have to do so you you feel more
in charge if that makes sense of not
only your life but the life that you're
trying to build yeah so I think that
really going back to that moment after
your kids said I love when you come to
visit was that like a right away change
or did it take a while for you to well
Co happened and I was like thank
goodness yeah um because in the you
could be home yeah oh no for the whole
the whole thing you're the guy that made
it in a lab I got to do something it
worked it worked D's home so uh no like
that happened in the worst Hallmark
movie he made he did what he had to
do and now his daughter loves him it
just beep beep and she's riding a bike
um I I think Daddy's home is a great
name too Daddy's yeah homid home
home for the holidays I I don't know
there's something home 19 home 19 home
their address is 19 yes home ed 19 and
your character name is Ed doesn't work
doesn't work we we'll Workshop it we'll
it will buy it yeah Val direct direct
she needs to break the break the seal
that's it yeah um I yeah I so I I I
think like when that happened it helped
like well but then Co happened and like
it was like you're dealing with all that
too on top of it so then I just found
myself in just a [__] storm of stuff but
like I it did make me think to be a
little bit more of a father that I
remember my father being you know like I
I I was just funny and silly and kind of
but I wasn't like somebody that they
would remember like I think about that
cuz my dad died when I was 19 and I
can't believe the impact they had in my
life in that much time that little time
yeah and I was like if I'm honest with
myself I'm not doing that now I am and
now I'm super proud of what I've become
but like then it was like I was a
stranger clearly she's telling me I'm
she's glad not come to is it you know
how old was she when she said that
five yeah yeah there I don't want to
ruin the story there there is a chance
that she didn't mean it that way you
know what I mean like they're just
saying it's like for to visit means like
I like when you're here yes that's not
take she probably didn't know what she
were saying yeah she called me Frank
Frank that was her I was like uh yeah no
but the I you're right too but it's just
but it could be just like you're looking
in the mirror right like it just forces
you to be like oh my God so that I felt
it that way she's right that's right it
doesn't matter what how she exactly
meant it but you heard it exactly and it
was happening so what was the first
change did you start saying no to stuff
no it was more being present and not
trying to do as much at the same time
which I was failing at because a lot hap
was happening with the work so the show
shuts down because of covid we have to
come up with a new show we do dinner
party so I'm working on that at home
um trying to produce that then you know
the movie had you know working on
editing the movie at the same time with
all this so it was like a right before
that so it was like just a lot of being
absent and I think a lot of it just
started like to I tried to do changes
but I wasn't super successful if I'm
going to be honest um and then until I
was forced to have to I think forced to
have to make changes for the better yeah
I see yeah so I think uh I think that
that was it you know I I I tried but you
I feel like too when you say like I you
probably could relate to this when you
think that you're doing enough you're
not like I felt like I was
doing just enough for it to be like you
know and I'm like isn't this great like
and it's like it's good right it's not
and you've already done a lot of like
it's not only doing the work it's like
fixing what you damaged the way you know
so I feel like that was part of it and I
relate to
also Val and I have to be
very open sometimes like okay it's today
so we live we live 90 minutes from here
I come in we do this
then I have I'm doing someone else's
podcast and then I have a show tonight
and that's that's a lot it doesn't sound
like a lot but by the end of the day
that's just the driving is is 3 hours in
the car plus the driving in LA right and
then I get home and we it's a weird
thing to be a clown yeah yeah and to
come home and be like but try to find a
loving way to say that and be like I
just need a minute to like shift gears
and it was it was Jed appow that was
like sometimes it's just a shower but
there needs to be something that carries
you over the threshold from what we're
doing which is very fun and easy I'm not
saying this is hard work right but it's
a different part of your brain yeah and
you said it what my daughter and you
have two kids what your kids want I I I
would say is what we all want but is
someone who's is being present and
responsive and reflecting to them yeah
like I saw my daughter is now five and I
just saw her last night I'm always
giving her like a lot of look very
improvy I'm locked on to her like a
scene partner yeah and like I'm starting
to see her noticing cuz for a while she
just thought everybody was that way and
now she's met enough other people to go
like they call the father's gaze or the
mother's gaze when a mom is
breastfeeding with the baby there's
there there's a shared gaze and that's
one of the ways that they bond so hard
so I'm always I can't do that I got no I
got no Teddy milk so the but the Gaze
the approving smile of the father for
sure is such a big deal yeah so I'm
trying to be real not just like every
single thing but let's be real every
single thing I do like yeah you know
what I mean yeah I I I at five it's
different because I my kids are eight
and six now so my son is six my
daughter's eight and with a 5-year-old
daughter I I remember like when they get
to
five like you hear all these different
theories about how you should act and I
just try to remember like I feel like my
parents did a good job and I remember I
like and of course you know they had all
their problems you don't know them they
probably did things wrong you don't know
you know you just feel that way about
them but I try to remember like things
that I remember to be good and I want to
do that with my kids so like I help them
with their homework and I remember my
mom was not a very smart lady and I was
like super smart and like she would sit
there and like try to do you know and
just but she would just be there with me
to do stuff you know so it's like I
think that was really like the part of
it like I and I had I started this new
thing whenever my kid ask and I I say
this to parents whenever your kid ask
you to play stop what you're doing and
play stop what you're doing and play
because there's going to be a time when
they don't anymore and the amount of
times they ask you to play over their
lifetime is what 50 that you don't have
that many important things to do like
there's nothing more important than
playing with your kid and so whenever my
K I drop whatever I'm doing I don't care
like I've missed stuff like I my I be
like I I move meeting zooms whatever
whatever I have to do I was like wow you
know I really that's been a takeaway for
me I was like this is a good way to be a
dad is just like to spend time they just
want to spend time that's is that's the
thing like your
mom the brain says I'm helping my kid
with my homework the heart says I'm with
my kids spend time yeah so the brain can
winh because the brain deals with the
brain stuff and it's almost talking to
itself it's like well I can't help my
kid with this math I can't do it just be
there and Lea is getting old enough now
that we can just be in the same room not
like she might be playing last night she
was playing with with a train I was
building a Lego uh Ninja Turtle and I
was
like I was so happy cuz I was like I
just want to be someone who can be near
you and not smother you and just kind of
be like a space heater yeah that's
that's great that's great if you need me
if you need a little warmth come over
here but uh cuz it can go too far as
well like the kid you can I I guess what
I'm saying is I'm aware of the potential
to like burden your child yeah like
opter then you're dealing with what you
need and that you a [__] what I mean
is you need a best friend like yeah I
mean when we were separated I was like
trying to almost fallen into that trap a
little bit where it was like that's
where it happened that was it's tough
and I was like oh and I was like but we
decided I was like look we're going to
get you know we're getting divorced I
don't want you know it's not us and that
and she was awesome we had dinner at the
house together even during the rough
even during the rough time like we had
dinner together at the house told my mom
this by the way cuz we have friends that
are split but they still have family
dinner like a couple times a week they
hang out they go to birthday they're
still a family and my mom was like that
is ridiculous I was like but what is the
alternative M like they just go away and
she was like don't get divorced and I
was like well people do get divorced but
then there's still a family and then I'm
saying goodbye to her and oh I I made
the mistake of saying this I was like if
Val and I got divorced we would stay
together as a family I thought that was
like a good thing to say you don't even
realize I might as well be talking about
what we're going to be like when we live
on Mars like it's the craziest thing all
she heard was me and Val are getting
divorced which is the farthest thing for
the truth but I'm leaving we don't talk
about it again couple days later I'm
going in uh her weird old lady bedroom
to say goodbye at like 6:00 in the
morning and I I give her a hug and a
kiss and I'm like I'm leaving and she
goes don't leave Val and I was like it's
not what I was saying don't mess this up
don't you do it I was like wow yeah they
just hear what they're going to hear now
these days I can go that's incredible so
you went from these dinners and again in
the spirit of
helpfulness what what started to thaw
the ice when I went to buy house because
I was living in an apartment act break
yeah firstperson get firstperson tocom
you can boost your dopamine and your
oxytocin you actually get some there's
right there no okay so when you bought a
house what do you mean that was just
such a good Cliffhanger here you
go I talk I talk in Cliffhangers
so a well I'd love to tell you stick
around pardon the interruption weirdos
this episode is brought To Us by our
newest petza pick which I am thrilled
about Air Doctor Americans spend an
average of 90% of their time indoors and
take about 20,000 breaths a day but the
indoor air that we breathe is 2 to five
times more polluted than outdoor air and
in some cases up to a 100 times more
polluted according to into the EPA and
did you know that air pollution is
responsible for nearly 7 million
premature deaths globally that's insane
so what is the solution introducing an
air purifier that captured the attention
of established media Outlets such as CNN
Money ABC and more our friends at Air
Doctor this is the best air filter that
I have ever found I love the way it
looks but I mostly love the way it works
Air Doctor filters out 99.99 % I said
that right
99.99% of dangerous contaminants so your
lungs don't have to this includes
pollutant such as allergens pollen pet
dander dust mite mold spores and even
bacteria and viruses that make you sick
air doctor comes with a 30-day breathe
easy money back guarantee so if you
don't love it just send it back for a
refund minus the shipping head to
apro.tv air purifiers exclusive to
podcast customers you will also receive
a threeyear warranty on any unit which
is an additional $84 value lock in the
special offer by going to air r d o c t
o r p r o.com and be sure to use the
promo code Pete support this podcast and
support youro lungs and your health in
the New Year speaking of lungs well
health ritual you guys know I'm a huge
believer in ritual multivitamins they
make my multi that I take every day and
they make my pre poost and probiotic
that I also take every single day same
for Val if supporting foundational
Health was a sport you would want ritual
on your team according to the CDC fewer
men than women meet the minimum daily
intake recommendations for fruits and
vegetables and men are more likely to
overvalue exercise and undervalue
nutrition what's the solution rich ual a
multivitamin scientifically developed to
help men fill nutrition gaps in their
diets and I can speak to this firsthand
I have my own anecdotal evidence I went
to the doctor they told me I was
deficient in this this this this this
that was before ritual now I go and I
knock it out of the park it fills those
gaps everybody always thinks you just
pee out the vitamins ritual has a
delayed release which means it doesn't
break down until it's in your lower
intestine where these nutrients can
actually be absorbed K 10 key nutrients
in two delayed release capsules per day
designed to dissolve later in the small
intestine an optimal place to absorb
nutrients also great for fasting it's
not going to make you sick if you
haven't eaten anything means it's gentle
on an empty stomach and even has a minty
Essence in every bottle that makes
taking your multis actually enjoyable
essential for men it's what I take I've
taken it for years it's a quality
multivitamin from a company you can
actually trust and you can get 40% off
your first month for a limited time at
ritual.com weird this offer is only
available through January 31st so jump
on it start ritual or add essential to
men and I also recommend their uh
symbiotic plus probiotic also they got
great stuff for all age groups and
genders of course go get a subscription
support your body support the show
that's ritual.com weird for 40% off all
right everybody back to Joe
so we I do dog rescue I have this uh dog
rescue that I do um and we were there's
this company in the city that wanted to
borrow some of our old dogs we do a
senior dog rescue Gatt pops and friends
it's mostly senior and unwanted dogs so
we have a bunch of old dogs it's it's G
pups G no you're saying your I saying my
name wrong got it I did pick it up that
you said it wrong I was I didn't do his
research uh can't do Audio
Research it's gate pups and now people
gonna spell it wrong um what did I say
G gate and it's gate Gat like G that's
what I said gate there you go gate okay
great we watch while we're at it it's
daughter not daughter daughter got it my
daughter my daughter never change every
time you say it I'm like it's
BFF not Balo no Balo okay got it um so
when I wanted to uh I was living in an
apartment complex and I was like this is
not the life I want for myself I'm going
to buy a house so um I said you know I
started I put a bit in for a house where
are you cuz I keep picturing you in Sten
Island uh Long Island I live in Long
Island yeah so I'm in Long Island live
on Long Island I live on Long Island not
in you don't live in an island uh you
live on an island we'll get back to it
so uh but you're in Manhattan which
makes no sense so I was I was uh these
people wanted to borrow some for Old
Dogs they needed them from 9:30 to 4:30
in the city and I was like listen we'll
just grab a hotel room um I said I'll
work and then you could just you know
take a nap and hang out she said okay so
we're in there and I get to note that I
didn't win the bid on the house I like
oh I didn't win the bid so then I opened
up and I started looking for another one
there was another house I liked and I
asked her I was like do you like I was
like what about this house you think
this one's okay and she said you're with
your wife at I'm with her yeah we're at
this event you know because we were
taking the dogs together they they need
like five dogs so I helped her bring
them in so then she said uh she just
said to me do you want to get back
together as I'm looking at she goes do
you want to get back together and I just
didn't filter it I said yeah do you and
she goes yeah yeah and that was it and
we just I we like look she started to
cry I shut the laptop and I was like
wait I said are you like you do and she
said she goes she goes yeah she's like
you know and then we just started
talking we talked all day and I said
well let's take our time with it I said
I don't want this to be a knee-jerk
reaction this was in May I think or
something and I said I don't want to be
this to be new reaction let's take our
time so we started going to dinners
hanging out having hard talks relaxing
you know uh I st kept my apartment and
then I just started to stay at the house
a couple started dating started dating
there's your movie much dating my wife
dating my wife uh so we started but it
was more than that it was more the
talking than the dating it was more just
being like open honest and being like
hey you know and then we got to uh a
point in August and I was like look I
said um I said I'm about to hit the road
again I said I would love not to live at
a three houses the road here and there I
said you know I took the summer off I
was able to take the summer off because
I'm in charge of my own thing I hung
with the family we did some good bonding
and I was like I'll ready to move back
in if you want to and she said yeah and
then that was it that was in August so
the the time between Zillow saving your
relationship yes yes yes if I if I won
that bid it's a totally different
outcome if I won that first house that
would have been your house that would my
house I would have had a house and the
second house was more of a family house
no the second house was no it would have
been they were both just like small
houses I didn't need a big house we have
the house it was like this would just
been I didn't want to live in an
apartment building and then she was like
do you want to come back our she was
like well yes this is our house kind of
thing cuz there was a part of me that
was like were you looking at the dopest
house ever and she was like do you want
to get back together let's live in this
house no we kept our family home she
stayed in our family home and uh cuz I
always wanted that to be where my kids
grew up and it's great great school
great neighborhood the house is great
but when I was like living in an
apartment complex and there was a fire
alarm that went off at 11:30 I had to
leave my apartment at 11:30 I'm like
what am I doing with my sopia this is
not where I should be so and I couldn't
have my dogs in the yard I had ding dong
fully out just standing with all the
hipsters and you're like what am I doing
people like ask get for
selfies um in my bathro it should be
with my daughter yeah my daughter do
daughter is that I saying daughter d d o
TT e r daughter yeah there you go got it
I like that you pointed out how it's
wrong in your learning my learning
you're like you mean like a different
word different word yeah that's it it
help me freak it up okay so yes what was
the what was the melting in the in
between so there's the split yep and I'm
picturing plates just kidding but
there's a split and you're a dingdong
and you had a lot to learn was it the
was it to my mom's point that this is a
good thing to do you having those
dinners was that kind of a slow melting
yeah well we both got to talk about our
beefs like there was stuff that was on
both sides of it yeah so we were split
so we were just being like kind of open
and honest you know like this is what I
needed this is what I needed this is
what I needed Back in Forth about stuff
this is why I didn't do that this is why
I didn't do that just talking and not in
a different tone not a defensive kind of
thing cuz you're already split yeah
right so it's like you know it's like
this is this is why I kind of feel
instead of this is what's bothering me
fix it it's more like this is why we're
broke you know kind of it reminds me of
deathbed epiphanies when you're already
dead you're like why was I why was I mad
yeah why was I so stressed why didn't I
talk to my brother for 10 years yeah
exactly yeah so so similar it was a
deathbed Zillow Resurrection I think I I
attributed to both I attributed equal
parts death yes yeah I had to put them
together but because the pressure was
off because mar Just cohabitating is is
a tense thing and it's I guess this is a
real argument for like it's hard to
maybe do that
growth together like while you're still
mad us to you get used to the way that
things are and then the things the the
way things are aren't the way that you
want them to be yeah but those are the
that's the way they are so it's like a
we it's a weird cyclical thing that you
needed to break it was more you know
look there's a lot of layers of this I'm
not I'm not you know going to get into
all of it but let's it's it's a trifle I
don't want to trifle about it we're
eating this it's just not right now we
have to eat it towards the end like Elon
Musk and Joe Rogan eating that pineapple
pizza it ruined the Audio I don't know
if you listened to that episode I was
like Jesus Christ nobody needs to hear
this smack um I ate five on the way in
you did did you already have some no I
didn't I have one at my uh in my hotel
room I dropped off one uh that's there
only five I bought six I love that you
got five from me I did well I didn't
know I didn't know this seems like a big
this seems like a big operation you put
on a hell of the front when you look at
it from that
side the wild west where it's just a
facade I know it's crazy cuz I walked in
it's not what you think people it's not
and we redid it we we've made this joke
before but Maryann Williamson did it and
she was like like clearly like like what
the [__] am I doing so we were like all
right we'll put up the backdrop and all
this stuff no you're like come in my
shed yeah come in my shed Presidential
nominee or whatever I guess she's not
the nominee yet yeah anyway here we go
where are we oh the melting was the
families and this the time apart and
what did you learn I know you've already
kind of hinted at it but like not hinted
but said some of the
things learn how to live on your own
that made a difference well no I think
being by yourself made you think
honestly you know and there's no you had
the quiet yeah the quiet and what was
your what was your again in the spirit
of helpfulness what was your blind spot
mine was that I was a man baby I was
selfish I was yeah secretly only cared
about
comedy yeah you know what I mean I was
like yeah sure keep the factory running
but then like my real life was outside
of the home what did anything take I I
equated providing with money yeah and
she you know she's always been
supportive uh still to this day loves my
ambition it's one of the things she
loves about me you know so it was never
anything like that it was never but it
was more of not totally ignoring
everything else and being like look I'm
out there doing it for us and she's like
yeah but this is the for us we need what
about this us what about here right you
know and then the other thing too I
think really that
helped with the was a realignment of
fatherhood which was being a real dad
that's somebody that she could be proud
of that that's her husband that's the
father he is as opposed to this guy who
was just like had a kind of a
relationship with a kid you know but now
it's like and you remember these little
moments that are things I remember the
first time they yelled Daddy and when
they woke up scared and said of Mommy
and I remember being like Oh that was
was thing I was I was like [__] call
for me I'm paying my kid off I'm like
say daddy wake up it sounds too big for
a lady this is definitely a monster a
big monster big monster yeah so I was I
so it was like things like that just
little things I was like just check-ins
for you that like oh you're doing
something right you're making
adjustments you know yeah so real quick
cute it is cute it's cute thank you in
the good way the good cute thank you
yeah no C is condescending I don't mean
it condescending I'm like it's very cool
that you were like I got it I hear it
and I'm going to change men and changing
no so much so much it's there's a
there's a lot though too but I mean it
was like I said it goes both ways in a
marriage too I don't think there's
accountability to be that you're the
problem but sometimes the problem is
that you're just not saying what you
think the problem is with other people
and you need you need something in
return so passive violence of of Silence
kind of 100% And I think that sounds
like a novel it does the passive
violence of Silence but that's real it's
like you think no you think you're it is
now it's like my movie body swap movie
nobody take nobody take these ideas uh
but like you think you're
being Peaceable by being quiet but
there's actually like a
festering a lot of my breakups before I
got married were because I just kept my
mouth shut because I didn't want to
fight yeah and I didn't want I didn't
want to rock the boat so they were all
out of the blue breakups a lot of the
time and I and I feel bad about that but
a lot of the times they'd be like what
and it's because I
didn't trust my own feelings I was
uncomfortable with my own uh dislikes
and I didn't want to share that's the
last thing I wanted them to know is that
I thought it was annoying when I did
this this this and that's a different
kind of feeding the Mirage you're
feeding the Mirage exactly you're being
well it's also what I learned to do as a
as a as a son was I was like nothing's
wrong everything's fine so I understand
why I did it but I had to learn to just
be like like my first divorce we lived
in uh Sleepy Hollow in upstate speaking
of spooky very monsters we were we lived
on gory Brook Road what are you doing
that was doomed from the GetGo from the
jump you gory Brook Ro that was to work
sley Hol behind a cemetery in a a thre
story house and everybody above and
below us was like actively like ill like
it was like the weirdest a very old
woman here and there was a very Coffey
and I don't want to make fun of sick
people but it was a weird feeling I
didn't feel like you making fun of sick
people I think you were painting a
picture I had riffs though
yeah you cut yourself off you're like
hold up there were Rifts but yeah I it
was it was a weird sandwich of sort of
like decay in a it's that what it that's
what it felt like and you're an Oreo of
Decay if you
will these are still cold these are
going to be so good do you want one now
Katie uh no I'll take one later yeah
well I'll have one when we cut we're not
we're not
rolling um but anyway I what was I
saying my first marri where you yeah
where you lived and oh and I didn't know
from that
experience I learned I'm I was
27 year when we did that now I look back
I'm like 27 yeah you're just starting
and couple things went well in my career
and then I was like in I felt invincible
and then I moved to Sleepy Hollow and
then I realized I'm mortal I'm very
mortal but the good part of that is now
with
Val I I knew going into that
relationship I was like there's certain
things I need that's why we lived at
this house for a long time I used to say
I was like I just need to know there's a
a mic an open mic that I can walk to if
I if I'm itchy I've calmed down a lot
since we moved out of the city again but
I was nervous but I learn I learned how
to speak up for myself and I learned the
passive violence of Silence right and
and that you need it's not loving to
move to Sleepy Hollow right when you are
screaming dude I've told this before but
we were walking the first night we spent
at that haunted house we were walking up
this deadly quiet street and I hated it
it was so quiet cuz I like the city I
used to go into the West Village and
just [__] just hang out and go to
show and I loved it I don't like it as
much as I do now but back then I was
like it's 27 the energy fed you yeah it
fed me and we're walking up this deadly
quiet gory Brook Road and Val uh Val and
my ex at the time my wife at the time my
ex now goes do you want to paint over
the wall because we painted the wall
should we paint over the wall and go
back to Brooklyn and a voice inside of
me screamed yes and I didn't listen I
went no and I was like I've heard that
voice scream since then and I've never
not it's like you with kids and playing
yeah that voice rarely screams right but
if it screams you go like you better
listen to it cuz there is a unconscious
or maybe a a body intelligence that
you're just like that knew yeah before I
knew yeah and it was VI it was a type of
violence to be like there's a connection
we should stay here yeah there's a
connection this is okay yeah what yeah
the mind is stupid sometimes it makes
you not speak that's right it's just
like it's irrational to speak but let's
get irrational baby you want to get nuts
yeah let's get nuts let's get nuts I
should have been nuts but you know she
was already having the affair I don't
know why she even did that to
meide she's like are you sure this is
the right place I was like I don't know
too far from too lately too far from my
other man yeah that's right yeah she's
like the commute is killing me gas
prices are rising um I don't mean to
make fun I love you no it's it's it's
totally in the Fun Zone okay she almost
got caught once because she was was
nervous we were on the phone and she
told me she was going somewhere but the
GPS was I think it might have been going
to Staten Island actually I'm not sure
about that but so the roads were wrong
it was like enter try borrow Bridge or
whatever she was like she trying to mute
it yeah this car's on the friends I told
you the way the technology can [__] up
Affairs oh it really was the death of it
it is death of Affairs being able to get
tked well I don't think it was Affairs
but David Spade had a joke I think where
he was like social media has ruined
everything like even if you're just
trying to not go out with somebody that
night because you don't want to and you
go out with your friends and someone
takes your
picture yeah it's ruined yeah you went
out with Frank what are you talking
about come on Spade you got to have a
little handicap I know a little bit out
there at the Playboy Mansion doing lines
from Tommy Boy [__] take a
handicap we got to knock you down a peg
that's right I did yeah I think I yeah
it's it's just weird it's just like
being self-aware is the hardest thing
and once you get you do the work to try
to like figure that part out it was like
you don't know yourself you don't yeah
and that's okay but you should know that
you don't know yourself yeah and we
should be more comfortable being like I
don't even maybe I don't even know what
I want but I I need to pause one of the
most powerful SS I heard and they had
helped me through a lot of it was it's
okay not to be okay like I always was
like it's okay everything's you know am
I'm a very optimistic person I'm a very
supportive friend family member I'm
always like that and then like I was
always like it'll be okay it'll be you
know I'm a fixer you know I got that
personality you know so it was like I
heard that and it just stuck with me at
a point when I wasn't okay to'd be like
oh maybe this is yeah it's yeah did a
little bit of reprogramming I think have
you heard this one is corny but uh wait
you read it at HomeGoods I read it
HomeGoods yeah this are the best I love
that wall I stand there and I just stare
and take it all on the wood oh my good
love the wood a w Good Wood sign this
deserves to be on a wood sign for men uh
is this a fix it or a feel it have you
heard that one that's great it is great
oh my goodness I'm embarrassed that's
awesome it's great are you like what are
you looking for you know what I like
people give a lot of [__] to the way
that we talk modern everyone's being
aware of feelings and it's like nobody
cares about when I was triggered in the
80s yeah the [__] 80s blew the 80s
blew and everyone's so much more
sensitive than they report to be like
it's hard uh I somebody texting me this
morning excited about the show tonight
and I'm like don't I don't want you
texting me that you're coming to the
show like they don't even know that they
upset me anyway was that me it was you
damn it was a comic it wouldn't bother
me but it's just it's it's the pilots in
the audience remember that on Seinfeld I
don't want to think about someone I know
being like I'll see you at the grocery
store but that that's my own [__] but
anyway uh I was talking to a friend who
was going through a hard thing and and I
I had to actively say because I'm a
fixing person and I'm an advice person
that's why it's nice to have this
podcast it's like a safe place to be
like let's let out all the advice here
but sometimes you're just like like our
kids it's like my daughter was s D that
she had to leave something behind I was
like yeah I know how you feel instead of
being like let's go get something else
or fix it just be like I know exactly
how you feel the same thing that was one
of the talks that we had while we were
separated oh really yeah my wife uh
Bessie said to me she goes uh it's okay
that she's not happy yeah and I was like
okay she's like you have to teach her
how to deal with not Toler happy
distress tolerance I don't know what
that is that's just that's a fancy way
of saying like they need practice Yeah
being unhappy because that happens
course and if you never let them
practice this sounds sadistic or
something but like if you get your first
job and all you've ever known is
marshmallow town it's not helpful so
sometimes it's the best thing to just be
like yeah it's disappointing this is
disappointed yeah it was it was a thing
they had to figure out I guess too but a
lot of that came from too was my limited
time with them yeah I was working on
whatever going about to go somewhere
packing unpacking you know it was kind
of like that that kind of thing so it
was like you want those moments to be
like of happiness and it was so selfish
yeah you know so that that was a big
learning learning curve too I think no
it's great it's great that you that you
changed yeah it's amazing that's right
so what happened with standup so you so
when I are you no longer on impr
practical J went back no no went back
don't want to go back no I I don't want
to you want to you want to get back you
want to get back together you want to
get back together yeah uh you know I'll
never say never but I mean I think I I
think you know when you get past a pro a
piece of something that was you're not
going to go back in like you're going to
continue your path that you're on now I
feel I did that for a decade it was you
know it was great I love it I love those
guys we're still friends we not friends
from work anymore that's what I say you
know I talk to them all the time they
you know we've been friends 35 years at
this point it's crazy wow so it's just
more like uh you know I have different
things I want to go to and and I've uh
it started with like okay I need to pay
the bills what can I do I'm an
Entertainer I've been on stage for a
while you know my whole life so my team
was like you could try stand up they
were like you know that that's an easy
transition for you to you know get up
there and do it so I called up Steve
Burn who's a good friend of mine and a
great comic and trusted Confidant sweet
guy he's great and uh smart guy too and
he's very and he's good he's very good
at advice and stuff he's a fellow
consigli we are to each other we like
always had that relationship and he's
also a balanced guy yeah pretty much
like he does where does he he does yeah
he lives in Nashville but he I remember
seeing him he lived out in LA and was
talking about that and spots and but he
made the choice he made the hard Choice
the Balan Choice balance Choice take the
we need those people yeah it's hard
there there's not a lot of them but the
alternative I don't like it for
you he always said that about me it's
actually so me and him do a podcast
called Two Cool Moms edit that out and
so he uh we didn't know what our podcast
was going to be we always wanted to work
together now that I had time I was like
let's do one you know so we started and
we we we called our first one yin-yang
parmesan because we didn't know what it
was we're like just two of us talk about
stuff and we always yinyang parmesan
yeah that's it and we we ended up
talking a lot about ourm as a
garnish go on sorry uh uh it's buala um
so I uh we started just always talking
about our moms and stuff and we always
were like generally advice givers shot
each other straight like told you know
talk to them so we were we always talk
to found ourselves talking
affectionately about our mothers and a
lot of that stuff and I was like oh
we're like two cool moms that give
motherly advice to people so that's what
our podcast started as was just like us
going back to what you're saying about
just airing grievances but then we're
like you know what let's try to help
people too in a fun way yeah we'll we'll
solve your dilemmas right in so we spend
the second half of it solving fans
submitted dilemmas but it always comes
from us being able to tell stories about
what people are going through because
it's a human experience we all figure
that stuff out so to be able to do that
stuff was like and now have all these
other different Outlets that I never had
like it would be something to give up to
go back to do what I used to do yeah so
it's a little weird you know I get that
and I and I always I I got in this game
I always say this I never wanted to be
on TV it was never what I wanted to do I
ended up on a show where I got to be
myself yeah you know I didn't play a
character I was Joe I am Joe you know
people see me and they're like oh he's
and then they see me they're like oh
you're just like you were on TV I'm like
that's cuz I didn't I was making my
friends like good afternoon I was like
good morning fellow you know so it's
like it was like but I always wanted to
be a writer and director now I'm chasing
that part of my dream and um I have my
family to think about and different
things it's so I don't I don't see it
right now you know all right we what
about the Wise
Guys you just reminded me you have your
family I my family got to remember your
family don't forget your family no no I
mean grow up in St Island you just and
as you get older you remember things are
like oh that was weird you know but it's
not Manhattan at Staten Island or has it
are there different families is it
really like that well I don't know the
ins and outs I just know my my you know
I know I can't talk about it I don't
trust you you're an
outsider not even Italian
homes no I'm not so I mean we shouldn't
be talking out School cut this I'll tell
you all the stories you want to know I'm
not going to say anything here that
could be proven I'm not going to talk
exhibit a with you on no this podcast
can't be played in the courtroom I if
you to tell me be a
cop but was it were you aware of it as a
kid I I yeah a little bit but not as
much as I got older I really I put thing
a little things together like little
things like my uncle my uncle Patty he
they called him fat Patty right he
worked for the Department of
Sanitation um and is that in quotes uh
yeah but no he really did drove a
garbage sh but also yeah yeah yeah so he
uh why that why was that because nobody
has any follow-up questions when you say
you work for station get rid of
everything get rid of the you get rid of
everything oh that's right get rid of
everything there's a kind of Genius to
that it's a 24-hour business it's always
open yeah somebody that could come and
do things night and things yeah okay so
they
my my dad was yeah know my dad was a my
dad was insurance salesman he's uh he
was a vice president of insurance
salesman company straight and narrow he
had a brother who was not he was not
straight and narrow and he went on
literally went on the lamb to uh to DC
he moved down to Virginia
so my my dad was like always just like
this straight narrow guy and we had this
mberry tree no mulberries so they're
like they're kind of like blackberries
and in stand on we had this huge mberry
tree but they all fell and they would
always get all all over everybody's feet
like mess up the house and stuff my dad
hated this tree he wanted to take it
down the tree was protected by the city
cuz it was on the city property but it
came into our yard typical big Mur
typical big mberry right so my my
fathers complained about this at a
family barbecue at Fourth of July
barbecue we complained about to my you
know my my uncle Patty's there you know
Fat Pat's there and we're just hanging
out talking so that we go to Hawaii's
family the scariest guy in the world
you're like Hey fatty fat Hey fat show
they're always bigger so he's like he's
like uh my so we go to Vaca we go on
vacation we go to Florida uh we go to
Hawaii as a family my dad has a
conference takes everybody we're in
Hawaii we come home we come back to the
house the mberry tree is in my yard over
the fence just down out of the thing
whatever so my my father is uh my
father's like what the hell happened to
mberry tree we go up to the door and
there's a note on the door and it says
uh tell the insurance company that the
wind knocked your knocked your tree down
love you cuz Fat Pat so he came at night
and he ran it over with the garbage
truck and knocked it down into the into
the yard so the insurance company
covered the tree getting removed and it
was a natural
cause a FAL
[Laughter]
cause yeah he did that he did that stuff
yeah and then my dad when as he got
older I was like oh I'll go Pat he like
go P weird and my dad started tell me
stories as I got older about like how he
used to do things when he was younger he
used to you know run numbers and do [__]
like that and then we got into his
father his brother who he never talked
to and I was like my dad was such a
family guy I was like you don't talk to
your to your brother anymore and he told
me the story about like how he kind of
[__] him he like took money ran he was
he was his brother yeah he was like so
the guys came to the house and my dad
literally did a FB an FBI sting in my
parents newly wed Kitchen in Staten
Island this guy came around looking for
money and it was like my mother was like
a No Nonsense she was like get the [__]
out of here she's like I married to his
brother that's not our problem he's like
it's your problem now one of those so my
father called the cops and they were
like we're actually looking to Ping this
guy up to something else he's like could
we run a sting and they hid in their
bathroom
waited for the guy to come over he laid
out the payment plan what was going to
happen blah blah blah and they busted
out and arrested in my parents kitchen
after he said it after he said it no
wires just a door just a door there a
cup on a door they're right in there
right in the bathroom waiting no [__]
this is like 19 this is like early
probably the 60s right um no no early
70s yeah because my sister was born in
70s so probably late 60s didn't have my
sister yet it's weird that both of those
stories even though they're from
different sides one's the FBI one's the
mafia I do just I think people just like
stories of uh agency you know what I
mean like taking care of stuff like we
did it we did it the tree's gone we got
this guy we got this guy everything's
good it's just fun the world is so I
always think of the soprano as one where
he wants to get the guy to sell his
house and he's going to sell his I think
it's a long island house to Tony and
then he changes his mind his wife talks
him out of it and then they have I I
love this and I hate this they have the
boat and they blast music and I'm just
like even though I feel bad I'm sort of
like there is something just sort of
undeniable about people that are like
it's open water I can't do it and we
played Dean Martin all night
everything's international waters you're
on the Jersey Shore what are you talking
about these are international water I'm
actually rewatching The Sopranos now for
like the fourth time I'm in season four
right now and it's it's just such a good
storytelling show and God I love gandle
was just perfect in it when I TR I tried
to get Val to watch after we had a baby
we just became a lot more sensitive I'm
not saying like how can you watch such a
violent show but um I we got to Ralphie
and once you get to Ralphie Val was like
I don't think I can it wasn't that she
didn't like it yeah but honestly my my
brother couldn't watch succession
because it was just too intense there's
certain things that ignite you in a
certain way and you just have to go I'm
going to I'm walking away yeah yeah not
everything's not for everybody but when
I was a young man uh younger man I
suppose the The Sopranos was exactly
what I was looking for just people
changing reality I think is interesting
people that are like like you said like
or defining their own reality that's
what I mean and I really my dad is is a
straight businessman but like I watched
him just like not not take no for an
answer but he's like so persuasive like
I tease my dad a lot but when I when I'm
with him I'm like oh my God he's kind of
like a politician and he makes things
happen and he's got that kind of I'm not
saying there's anything Mafia here and
I'm not defending the mafia I'm just
saying the mafia doesn't
exist this thing of
ours now it's ours listen I just brought
your trifle okay it's not even some B
this was a this was a this
Azel it kind of looks like it I just
mean creative thinking I we'll always
like people whether it's Iron Man or
Tony Soprano that are going around in
the world going like I keep getting a
lot of nose and someone's like I'm going
to make a suit out of iron or somebody's
like I'm going to put a boat in the
water and play loud music or whatever it
is and I know it gets murderous and all
that stuff but I don't think people like
murder they like people who are afraid
vulnerable like all of us and are are
acting unafraid and and the world isn't
happening to them they're happening to
the world yeah which is very like my dad
the only person totus Brown was afraid
of was his wife exactly it's crazy right
they did such a good job if you watch
that yeah his mother was more of a
disappointment thing but like he like he
was afraid the scen some scenes with
Carmella some of the best TV ever made
man and she was unbelievable the Golden
Heart Golden Heart on a little chain
it's like you're like up against the
wall when he punches when he punches the
sheetrock like that was probably the
most intense TV moment I think I've seen
oh I know ever like that the the two
100% the two of them face to face in
that that was just some great actors
characters that they knew inside and out
just yeah I have a theory that the
reason why people don't like the finale
is because we were just talking about
this you want your deaths to be third
person MH you don't and that's a first
person death he goes black oh you think
he died oh yeah oh interesting I'm sorry
did not did that did that not reach the
island he's dead no I I well I you know
it's all up for interpretation and
that's the kind of thing it was for me I
I heard David Chase says he's dead well
that's David Chase's opinion he made it
who's he to say he's not Tony saano uh
the one thing I would the the thing I
would say though that I heard before
well it took him a while to say that as
well so there's a lot of speculation but
the thing that I heard that I like about
it was you didn't meet Tony Soprano when
he was born so why does he have to be
dead you never meet a character when
they're coming out of the womb right you
see their story from a moment to a
moment they're like so that was just the
end moment that they got to see them
from you know and the rest of
speculation look at you you can't let go
of Tony I don't I don't want to you
can't do I don't think I have to here he
comes every Christmas he's on DVD I can
watch her whatever I want um that's
hilarious okay uh we usually talk a
little bit about I feel like we've I
feel great we could end right now so we
don't have to go on and on if you don't
want we we talk about the meaning of
life do you have any framework for
what's going on I mean what the hell
have we' been talking about this whole
time I feel like we got very long that's
the meaning of like a of a of a good
life like the strategy of of happiness
and family and meaning we've talked
about that I would say the meaning the
meaning of life you mean well I I just
think kindness is goes is way under sold
yeah be kind is a mantra for me I think
it's very important because everybody's
going through something and I mean even
being on the side of entertainers people
that are up there to make people laugh
or there's been you know two minutes
before Showtime before you have to go on
you're probably in your head space
miserable yeah I mean it's happened to
me I'm not saying you I don't know you
for sure do you want to talk
about like how long do you have um but
yeah I think I think it's really
important like a little bit of kindness
goes a long way smiling at a stranger
paying it forward all that stuff that
feeds into that is like humanity is
really fragile and I think we're all
feeling that right now so I would just
say you know stay strong and be kind is
really like two things that really have
yeah helped me and you lost your dad
when you were 19 do you have any sense
of an afterlife or is it
just no I
don't I don't I I think people live on
inside you with memory and whatnot you
know I've had weird experiences because
because of my dad and I I think you
connect them and make them happen one or
two seem unexplainable but like besides
that it's like I don't know what goes
like
what so I was I was working in
Philadelphia uh born and raised you
really seem like a guy that would say
Philly I was I want to give it the full
thing here oh yeah yeah Peter hes Peter
Holmes so I want I was living in Philly
and I uh I was working for my my I got
my degree in accounting so I knew I
didn't want do accounting so I end up
Consulting the Consulting world and I
was working for Accentra this big
consulting firm working down in Philly
and I had to drive up from New York
every Monday so I was driving and I Liv
there for the week so I was driving up
and I had cut through this parking lot
and I was thinking of my dad I was in my
Fields I had just lost him and I was
like he would have been so proud of you
know me going to work I had a suit on
you know like that and I was just
thinking about that I was in my Fields a
little bit I think a song was on the
radio and as I'm driving I'm going
through this parking lot and there's
just this I just fixate for no reason on
an acorn
in a tree and I have good long long
Vision it's a humble break Long Island
Vision Long Island Vision so I could see
far away so I see this it's I can see
mon talk from the from the Western point
I have the windows down I'm just hanging
out listening to the radio and I'm
driving I'm in my Fields a little bit
and I'm thinking to myself I was like I
just wish I could hug my dad and be like
he could hug me and tell me how proud he
was and as I'm driving I see this Acorn
and I'm watching an acorn and I'm
driving it and I see the acorn full I'm
going like 20 M hour through a parking
lot 10 miles hour slowly bought the
acorn pre pre fall so I see it fall out
for some reason I see this Acorn it
falls out of the tree and I'm driving
with my window down it bounces off the
floor and it lands here and I catch it
in my neck like when you hug somebody
swear to God and I was like and I just
stopped the car and I like cried for
like 10 minutes oh my I still have the
God I hope you still have the yeah so
that was a one that seemed really like
unexplainable like I was like that's
pretty weird I feel like my dad reached
out and was like hey everything's going
to be okay kind of thing um you know but
the rest of that I always feel like it's
all about impression of like the
impression that you make on people and I
think people keep you alive yeah I think
people in their memory you have your
impact what your legacy and I and I'm a
firm believer in that as far as like
heaven and and all that stuff and you
know what goes on to your body and all
that I don't I don't know I nobody knows
it's all speculation so I don't waste my
time thinking about that stuff really I
just try to live a good life and you're
just out there hugging acorns I'm
hugging acorns I'm getting out there H I
don't want to talk about religion I'm
just going to hug an acorn and shut the
[__] just get acor some people and your
dad's name was fog horn acor AC I say I
say I say he was a great man I was a
very proud of you on that big day you
did well my boy in your fan you had your
suit on CPA drinking a Le lemonade in
April too that's your B business oh you
had to be very a
clamp well we've done it oh this is
great can you tell me en closing a time
that you laughed really really really
really really hard um I did stand out
when you said you used to to make S
laugh really hard so I'm wondering like
a big laugh that you remember it doesn't
have to be with s a big laugh that I
remember did you know when I saw taste
buds for the first time I didn't know s
so I thought Joe had just
found a guy like a funny guy oh that's
so funny like I thought there was just a
guy at the barber shop and that is kind
of the appeal of of all you guys is like
there's a certain it's not pretentious I
was like and then he was being so funny
and I was like what the [__] is going on
here but I had no idea s is probably we
say this about each other I think I
don't know he knows a lot of funny
people now but we always said that we
were funny the funniest people we know
yeah I would always say he's the
funniest guy know and I'd always he'd
always say I was but I think there's a
specific the way no one makes s laugh
the way I make S laugh like there's just
a thing and one of the hardest laughs we
had was actually a character that we
brought back in the show years later I
had just done as a bit in the bathroom
so he used to he used to do this thing
where he
uh he would stay at my mom's house at
our basement we would play video games
and just he would sleep over we were
like in our 30s so
uh same
bed so he was like uh he was just over
and then one night like I just got Giddy
and we got stupid and I made up this
character and his name was Co Von Cole c
e v and Co and I would I would just be
like I was I was like I have to get up
early tomorrow and I just started making
this stuff up like I was like I'm
playing I have a tea time with Owen
Wilson and and I kept saying all this
stupid stuff and he just started
laughing laughing laughing and it got
him so bad that he was laughing so hard
he was like stop it and was like
literally sides splitting and he went in
my bathroom and he threw up and and as
he's throwing up I'm still doing the bit
and he's trying to get me out as I'm in
the bathroom that was one of the hardest
I you did a bar bit that's it I did so
and Co Von Cole and then later years
later we did this bit in the show where
we had to disguise ourselves as somebody
and fool them to think we're somebody
else so I dressed up as kovon Cole and
as soon as I turned the corner and I in
myself as introduced myself as him s
lost it yeah did ruin the oh yeah no he
I I was on the floor so he was in the
back he life as AR loud as he wanted and
and then that became one of my most
famous characters on the show and it was
just like a full circle moment yeah oh
God I love it you really preserved
something special and precious just in
your life and in the show and in your
comedy it's just it's wonderful to see
yeah thank you hey cor just fallowing us
a hug him hug him as I I will say too
you are a very very great guy because I
didn't know you should cuz no but
genuinely I didn't know you I literally
met you and I was I was genuinely
excited to meet you you've made me laugh
lot and I just always felt like you're a
really great guy and sitting here with
you I I agree with my original Cheers
Cheers I really appreciate and you
brought five desserts that's really nice
man no there are people that you're just
like you know in the green room I was
like this guy's all right and I was
really excited to talk to you and I'm
really glad you did it thank you for
taking the time thanks for having me
would you say keep it crispy it's just
written on that sign as if you need to
read it do I look at this but nobody
sees me no you don't have to look at it
keep it crisp
and you get oh you didn't drink your
magic mine you get a magic mine I get a
magic you have similar hair to me you
can have some Modern mammals that's the
sh I have simar hair do you you have
how's your eyesight how's your
eyesight you have straight hair oh
talking about keeping it
crispy just trying to keep it doing what
I can I have one angle I can't really
and and you had me sitting this way the
whole time this is terrible for me I
have to be like
this it's the only way my hair looks
okay I'm really glad I made that
mistake well thank you for doing it
thank you did you say keep it crispy
keep it
crispy you made it you made it oh yeah
you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it you made it you made it
with oh yeah you made it with you made
it with you made it with all yeah